[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm rhett and i'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
am i am i talking to rhett i don't am i
talking to somebody else am i talking to
an alter ego i don't know because we're
about to get into
this is this is like breaking open the
seal on a
on something that you've been you've
been keeping under wraps my friend
there's parts of this that we're gonna
discuss today
i'm excited about because uh
it i think we're gonna discuss it on a
level that we haven't
well
here's the interesting thing is that by
the time this podcast now we're we're
recording a little bit earlier because
we're about to do some traveling
uh
and i haven't i have talked about this
like on my personal social media right
in the in in by this by this point but i
haven't seen any of that yet but
as i'm talking right now
so few people know about this it's just
kind of it's we it's weird to be talking
to you ear biscuiteers about it because
and it's thinking about it for a long
time what
i
have been working on
a solo
music project
under a
name that is not
rhett
but is still kind of my name because my
middle name is james
it's called james and the shame and it
is a country music project
essentially an album
with some singles the first single
dropped
on friday
called believe me
and we're going to listen to that yeah
and and talk about it and there's this
episode another single coming in
august and then there's another single
and the album coming in september and
this is a
for lack of a better word is a concept
album what's the name of the album
well that's interesting because am i
committing to it right now what do you
mean
i don't know i i i have something
okay save it i have i have something in
mind but i'm gonna i'm gonna i might
know by the time this is goes live but i
haven't fully committed i wanna discuss
that you're playing the marketing game
with me i don't know the name of the
album no i have a name in mind okay but
you're not going to say that you're not
going to release because i might change
it slightly you're not you're going to
release the track list like a
i don't know
but anyway it is a that's what artists
do man i'll get into the uh i'm going to
get into all the details of why this is
happening how this happened how long
it's been whatever who the features are
um yeah also who the features aren't um
yeah uh
but what i will say what i'm saying is
i'm not featured it is a
we'll be we'll talk about that it is an
exploration of my spiritual
deconstruction through
the means of country music
um
and so i tried to come up with a cool
way to describe that like yeah
deconstruction and country but all i
came up with is d country
which is which is not great so that's
not you're still trying to figure out
how to talk about this project this is
an interesting thing
because
this is not like this isn't this isn't
my day job my day job is what we do this
is my hobby and my side gig
interestingly you're you've got this new
crazy watch that you're wearing for the
first time and it's making all kinds of
light oh it's analyzing everything but
like it's like shot almost shot it's so
loose right why is it so loose because
it's it's so loose when you go like this
it's shining in my eye
uh
i'm sorry christy christie said the same
thing i gotta i gotta figure it out i
gotta figure out if i wanna christy's
christie said it was too loose she said
it was shining in her eyes too
well it's analyzing like my my
biometrics but it needs to be tightly
analyzing it not like from a distance
but i feel like if it gets too tight
then my hand will fall off
well that's well
that's a whole nother episode yeah yeah
yeah i'm not making this about me but so
but what i'm getting at is
this isn't something that i've been like
scheming and thinking about in a really
strategic way
it's a very organic thing that just so
this is actually a lot of the things
that i'm saying right now first time
i've thought about them first time i
thought about like oh how do you
and i me and i actually made the
commitment to myself like last night i
was like should i think about what i'm
going to say i was like no that's what
this forum is for it's like
i'm just going to think about it out
loud because i've just been focusing on
getting the music done and being happy
with the music and a couple of the
things that you have to do like well you
got to have album art
okay you know and that kind of thing so
but i haven't been thinking about this
from a how am i going to talk about this
to people who aren't already our fans
and already mythical beasts somebody
who's like i'm just a person who listens
to country music and there's a new
artist out there and i'm going to check
them out well they're not listening to
this
so this is different yeah well
we'll talk about that who i think who i
think it's for yeah but we know who's
listening to this
oh yeah yeah yeah just mythical beasts
uh
i
if i may make a suggestion about like
formatting of this thing i don't i i
would like to talk about the project
um and and really get into the details
of it and
kind of to the point we were just making
for this audience and for this venue
what i don't want to do is i don't want
to start making it about like what does
it mean for us first but i i would like
to get into that i think that you know
uh
listeners will be interested in like
what
what it
how is this played out in terms of our
dynamic for for you to be doing this
solo project
yeah because rat going solo how does
what what's my take on that how did
what are both of our experiences with
you doing a
the first bona fide solo project even if
it is a side project and a hobby thing
it
you know i think that's something for us
to work out but not work out but
something for us to just talk through
yeah we talked through it a little bit
but i think that would be a
uh
a good
edifying conversation my answer some
questions that people have like what is
it if you because i'm sure i actually
that wasn't one of my worries in doing
this thing we'll talk well you know
we'll talk about that we're going to say
like you said you're going to say that
for the second half of the conversation
let's talk about how this happens that's
exactly what i'm saying let's save it
for the second half of the conversation
after we've just talked about
the project in and of itself
okay you know so
okay so how did this happen how did this
happen and and can i just make a quick
plug
yeah uh because it's very timely as of
the the release of this episode
uh i'm doing an ama you know every month
we do an ama on the mythical society
it's on discord uh but you're going so
live
i'm actually going solo but i'm bringing
on another guest lily so lily my
daughter and i are are doing an ama on
the mythical society today
at what is the day's date
is july 18th in the year 2022 yep at 3
30 pacific 6 30 eastern on the discord
of the mythical society we're doing an
hour-long ama
so uh
tune into that and if you're listening
to this later all the amas the ones we
do every single month and the one i'm
doing with lily today will be archived
so you can like read through all the
questions and our answers and
so that's today
so let's get into it james
um should i call you james the rest of
today
um
you know i mean comment call me what you
want to say yeah
james is the name i use when i order
food from any place including starbucks
because it's a name people can
understand but now it's your but now
it's my
i wouldn't call this an alter ego
because an alter ego is you purposely
tried to disassociate yourself from
and this is just like rhett james
mclaughlin who is me has a solo music
project that is called james and the
shame
i'm still working on the best way to to
explain that but we'll talk about why
i'm not just hey why aren't you just
mclaughlin we'll get to that so how did
this start
so
obviously um
you know
i have a guitar
let's let's start there
i don't think i know the answer to this
by the way so yeah so very
very interesting so the two of us have
written and recorded i actually it's
funny because i was putting together the
the bio that's going to be like on
spotify etc
you and i have written and recorded over
a hundred songs
easily over a hundred it might be close
to 150 but like wow um
and so
because i wrote something like a stark
departure from his over 100 multi-genre
comedic songs written and recorded as
part of the duo rhett and link
you know should have said a lonely
island um it would have helped you i
think we've written and recorded more
way more songs than lonely island maybe
not as good but a lot more we're more
prolific in certain ways in terms of the
number of tracks
but we've written a lot of music and
uh you know
the majority of that music was written
in a way where it was like i had a
guitar somewhere and i would like come
up with some
some
rhythm and structure and just like put
it in a voice memo and then show up and
we would write to it right
so it has been a habit over the past 20
years i've got a guitar in every place
that i go i've got a guitar in the
office i got a guitar in my bedroom
but we tend to get really busy with
things and i'll go months without
picking my guitar up and
we just get
so deep into some new project that may
or may not have music
and if it doesn't have music it's just
like i'm not picking my guitar up my
fingers start i was like ah i don't have
calluses anymore like they wear off
but
i think it was 2019
and my guitar is in in my bedroom and i
pick it up and i'm kind of like just
diddling around on it
and the next thing you know i'm biddling
yourself i'm beginning to
write us this is now this is unusual
because
i've never done this
in the past 20 years
if i start playing something and start
singing something and start writing
something it is always exclusively
uh what i would call a business decision
okay it means i am writing this song as
part of
the mythical thing that me and you have
built together and it is obviously going
to be for the purpose it's comedy song
it's yeah we could use this in something
or whatever or or i need to write a song
for buddy system soundtrack or something
like that right right which i think is
the last time we were really intensely
writing songs was buddy system season
two
and it was so well actually it was the
music for the tour the the that's it
right
the few songs
the few new songs that we like why
travel kyle
the shirt song which interestingly
enough like so buddy system season two
it was it was very collaborative
it was very um last minute to the point
where we were going on separate
vacations right before filming and we
had to divide up songs something we had
never done and you said yeah because we
were so under under the gun we're still
under the gun i had to i had to write
one song you had to write another song
and we had to commit that we were both
going to bring them back basically done
yeah which was
unusual and then when we for the tour
um
uh the retin link live tour
in 2019
you wanted to start playing piano and so
then you like you made yourself write
why i travel on the piano that really
wasn't
i i didn't i didn't add too much of that
song as much as i recall i don't recall
that doing much to it and then
and the other ones like kyle that was a
little more collaborative and then the
the shirt song
it just isn't memorable
i mean i don't remember
the shirt song is a is performance art
it's not really a song that you want to
listen to
yeah it's a song but but those songs you
might want to watch you just kind of
went away and wrote those because again
we were in this divide and conquer mode
and it and music
you know when the tour was kind of like
get it get in where you fit in kind of
thing yeah so there was a little bit of
even in that yeah you would sit you
started more and more
initiating retin-linked songs on your
own
but this time
in 2019 you sat down you weren't
thinking about a business move you
weren't thinking about an obligation a
creative obligation i was like i've got
this idea
and really it wasn't like i'm going to
sit down and write a song it was like
i'm playing the guitar and i kind of
like what i'm hearing here and
i'm just starting to kind of sing a
melody usually i'll sing a melody that
is nonsensical words that just sound
good and i'll make a voice memo just so
it's just like oh i want to remember
this melody that i came up with and you
sit you sing words that sound good that
don't make sense right this is very
common songwriting technique and so
but i was like
see i was
saying words that did make sense and i
realized that i was
writing a song to god
okay it was writing a song to god
oh and when i say writing a song to god
as someone who doesn't necessarily
believe in god at this point
i was writing a song to
the idea that i had of god in the past
and you know
basically writing a song
like i had a relationship with you
so if you don't know do you remember the
first line that kind of came out of it
i still remember when we used to talk
you never said much but i knew what you
thought
um
so that was the first line that came out
and so
i was like oh this is kind of like if
you don't if you're not if you're not a
christian or a former christian or a
spiritual person maybe you wouldn't pick
up on the thematic imagery here and you
might think i'm just writing a song
about a lost love because it's about a
relationship that you had and like
being like i've got these old it's
called old letters it's like i've got
these old letters that you wrote to me
and i and i sit down and read them
the bible you know i don't like giving
all the i want you to listen to the
music and interpret it for yourself but
this one's pretty obvious i guess
um
but i was writing it and i was like i
don't know who this is for i don't know
why i don't know i like i'm not like i'm
writing a song because i'm going to have
a music project one day it was very much
just like
oh this is coming out of me in a very
easy way like and i'm not it's
interesting because i'm not trying to be
funny
there's no jokes in this song
it's very serious and it's very sincere
and it happened very quickly that's one
of the things about
almost all there's 11 songs on the
finished album and all of them
you know the process between beginning
to write and then record or like
fine-tuning the lyrics that may have
been a month long process but
with rare exception the writing of the
music in the first pass of the song is
usually something that happens when i
just sit down and do it in about
one to two hours and you go i've got a
song right i'm gonna come back i'll
change that lyric i'll work on that
whatever but they usually come out
really easy if they if i sit down in
this heart i'm like
i'm doing this for fun
it's not a business decision it's not a
job so i'm not there's no forced
creative so so this first song letters
yeah it's
it it came out
it pretty much
came to it formed
in that sitting and then what so
i sat down and like recorded i recorded
a demo of it but i wouldn't have called
it a demo i was just like oh i'm going
to record this and i actually recorded
it in like the evernote audio
record i don't know if you've ever done
this but like
evernote has you can press add audio and
it's
so low quality it sounds like something
like out of the 20s compared to like if
you just do a voice memo and attach it
interestingly
um
and i was just like okay i did that now
this is 2019.
at some point after that
i would say
months after that
i just kind of told my therapist about
it
i was like yeah i you know i i i wrote
we we were having lunch can you pull it
up play a little bit of it
i don't want to do that because that's
not that's not the that's not the single
okay it's actually the last song on the
album okay
um maybe i'll play that when uh because
you can see how different the final
version ended up being or maybe
once the album comes out
um but i'm talking to my therapist about
it and we were having a lot of broader
conversations about
me getting into a place where i was in
creative flow and him just making record
just recognizing like seems like when
you are
in you're healthy and you're thriving
and you're experiencing joy when you're
in a creative flow now obviously i'm in
a creative flow a lot with what we do
for a living because this is a creative
business this is a content business so
i'm doing lots of writing i'm do you
know i'm doing a lot of creative things
but it's also a very sophisticated
business with a lot of moving parts and
those business parts which i do think
that both of us are really good at isn't
necessarily
life-giving and
doesn't breathe a lot of joy it's kind
of like well if you want to do this
right you got to do this right so you
got to answer these business questions
et cetera et cetera yeah for other
people business can get them into flow
but that's not really our thing yeah and
so
he would
my therapist without getting specific
was just like
saying like yeah you should just you
know
i'm telling him about writing this song
he's like you when you talk about that
you know i kind of see you light up a
little bit so i just encour i would just
encourage you to continue to just you
know
express yourself creatively as a
and move towards things where you can
express yourself creatively he wasn't
being like go do an album
um
so i you know it wasn't like i was like
okay yes i'm gonna do that it was like
yeah yeah i really enjoyed that maybe
i'll do it again
pandemic rolls around 20 20. yeah
and
our lives changed drastically like
everyone else's we were obviously still
really busy we were doing everything
that we were doing with mythical and
trying to keep all our content streams
going
but you know
less travel more time at home
um i got this guitar in my bedroom i got
a guitar at the creative house i got a
guitar here i got guitars everywhere
right and so i just found myself as a
way of sort of like passing the time
picking up
my guitar and beginning to play and i
just started finding that every time i
did that
a song would come out of nowhere right
and
so then
before i knew it i had written a song
to my parents
i had written a song
to my children
i had written a song
to my wife
you know i talked about the song that i
wrote for valentine's day that we know
we we talked about on the podcast yeah
that i played for her which is
a song that i ended up writing for her
uh
oh yeah you're telling me you're not
talking about when you were dating
you're talking about like i did when i
was dating too i'm talking about like
you did a 20 20. it's probably twenty
twenty twenty one valentine's day is
when i probably talked about it
okay um
but
all what was happening was is all
without any real calculation all the
songs that i was writing were more like
it was a
cathartic sort of therapeutic way of
thinking about my deconstruction so i
point out those songs and one to my
parents one of my kids one of my wife
as
what was happening with me is
i've had this very long process of
deconstruction
and as i've talked about many times my
spiritual deconstruction
on its surface is it was a very
intellectual thing right i wasn't
wronged by someone emotionally i didn't
have a pastor do me wrong i wasn't like
i didn't have the
you know the rug pulled out from
underneath me it was just a very slow
process of access to new information
that was
increasingly more difficult to reconcile
with my christian worldview
to the point to the breaking point right
but that doesn't mean that there weren't
incredibly heavy emotional things
happening relational things like
deconstructing
from a faith that your parents gave you
and they still have
being a father to kids when they were
born you're taking them up in front of
the church and dedicating them to god
and then no longer believing in that god
in the same way and no longer adhering
to a biblical or christian worldview and
still wanting the best for them what is
that so what i would find is that
the way for me to process all these
emotions was to write a song about it so
i started talking more and more to my
therapist about this and he was like
this is bringing something out in you
like
and just started talking to jesse about
it she was like
it's not you know anyone who knows me
well
knows that
it's you know i am a i am a very
emotional person but so on the surface
it'd be you don't you don't see you
don't see that but there's a lot there's
a lot going on
you got to kind of tap into it and you
got to it has to come out in a certain
way for you to be like oh this dude was
feeling a whole lot of things
and so
i just kept going and going and again
the thought as i was writing these songs
was like
this is a therapeutic cathartic process
now of course
i am a full-time entertainer
uh and so as i'm getting to like the
third and fourth song i'm like
i'm making something here
yes i'm doing this
for myself yes it is a therapeutic
process yes i do feel like there's like
an emotional release every time i do
this
but i'm making something here it's kind
of you know yeah it's this
there's a tension of
i mean
yeah you're doing something for therapy
but then you're also
a you're not just a creative person but
you are an entertainer
and so i mean there's echoes of the
conversation that we had about like why
you're growing your hair out like this
it originated in therapy and you were
like
it was a therapeutic exercise but at a
certain point you're like i actually
think
i will look good with my hair like this
i think my wife will like me better i
think that this
this fits into my brand you know these
things are things that you can't help
but think about because of the position
that you have and not just that it's
also my personality as an enneagram
three which i don't you know not
everybody
every some people get tired of hearing
about the enneagram i get it but the
enneagram three just think about it this
way it just means you're performance
minded it means that you find your value
and your worth in what you can
perform for people in winning right
right so there's and it's very unhealthy
it can it can be very unhealthy and it
goes with you into every endeavor even
like something that
like nothing for anybody
is is like absolutely pure it's like
we're not you know
uh but that doesn't mean you can't
be aware of it and still have
like i believe that this can be a um
relatively pure endeavor well it's funny
because i've i have a song that i've
already written i've written multiple
additional songs that are not on the
album that i guess will be for something
in the future but one of them is about
this exact process
you know that talks about i
i ain't sure what i'm trying to prove or
who i'm trying to prove it to
you know what i'm saying like that's
that that's the treadmill that the three
is on constantly which is really me i
wrote it when i when we i finished the
the album and i'm thinking about this
process that i'm in right now which you
know because i've been telling you about
it like
it's one thing to write the music
and i love the process of writing i love
the process of recording i love the
process of collaborating with talented
people who make what i wrote better than
what it would be if i was the one in
charge from the beginning to the end
i love all that
uh but as i get into the process of like
okay well you have to like have a bio
and you got to have like you got to get
pictures taken
once i started beginning to do these
things that feel very performative and
marketing oriented is when i started
thinking about the
built-in irony of doing something that
is
personal cathartic therapeutic
beneficial to me and then turning it
into a consumable product which is
checking all the three's performance
boxes
so i wrote a song about that
but it's not on the album because it's
about the process of doing this right
so but just to go back so at a certain
point you had amassed
a number of songs
like what was you made a decision that
you were going to make this an album
well when i got to like four songs i was
like
two more songs and i've got like an ep i
mean
you can do a four song ep but i was like
a six song ep like that's that's that's
respectable that's something
i can i can write two so but that
process was very much it wasn't
calculated it was like i as i would keep
talking about this stuff with with my
therapist and with jesse
i'd be like you know
i feel like these songs need to be
released into the wild they need to be
put into the world and here's my
thinking on that
so
you know that i'm a big fan of
david bazan
uh who pedro the lion
he's uh he's probably even more known
for his advantage
so uh
he is a guy that grew up in a christian
home
and was very much a you know strong very
similar story
and then he deconstructed
and he was actually making like
christian music i think back in the day
with pedro the lion and then of course
he deconstructed and it kind of
his music evolved with his world view
but he made an album probably in the
late two to the alts like 2008 2009
called curse
curse the branches cursor branches or
curse the branches
um
and
it was essentially his deconstruction
album right and it was a little bit of
an angry album uh in that he was kind of
like he was you know a little bit angry
at the world that he had come from
uh but also it was just
deeply
it was so thoughtful and so like
specifically connecting to what i now i
wasn't listening to it in 2008 2009 when
it came out i listened to it probably
uh almost 10 years later yeah i listened
to it once and
it just
yeah it was it was a bit of a downer
yeah but i was just like man this is
this is so meaningful to me because of
my particular experience yeah and i was
like you know i'd i'd love to make the
album that i would want to listen to
right yes i've heard that before write
the book that you would want to read
i was like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna make
this music it's the music that i would
want to listen to as someone who's kind
of been through
or going through what i went through
um and so then it was like this could be
a gift to those people who have
who can relate to this story can you
know and not just people who again it's
this is a this is a super niche thing
again it's
very much a country album which is not
necessarily like the most popular genre
of music
uh but it's the it's the genre of music
that i can
personally write and sing in a credible
way let's get more into that after
listening to it uh
but
it's my per it's also personally my
favorite type of music
um but the subject matter
is very s
at least for this this album is very
specific because every song is related
to that process yeah and again that's
when it became this thing like well this
should be something that is released
because
it's it's so deeply personal and
emotional and i know that there's so
many people out there going this is this
is a cultural movement we talked about
it many times people
reevaluating their traditional world
views whatever your traditional world
view doesn't have to be christianity
specifically but like we're in an era
where you're bombarded with so many
perspectives and so much information
that it's becoming increasingly
difficult to hold on to any traditional
view that requires putting your blinders
on and blocking out everyone else's
perspective
and so we're this is a cultural upheaval
which i think ultimately will be for the
best but so many people can relate that
i hope that regardless of their
circumstances it'll be like ah this you
can connect with this music and it can
be
uh a gift to people you know
so that's when it became like i'm gonna
release this but that was all that
happened
and
um but of course i hadn't recorded
anything beyond demos
and so this is the second piece of the
puzzle
uh because i didn't know how it was
gonna become a thing right
we developed a relationship with derrick
furman who was britain's producer on on
your cousin brenton buchanan on his his
stuff
and he started producing our music
producing mythical society the lionel
richie stuff the brooks and dunn stuff
the hazel the hazel project yeah uh and
just love the dude and just love the way
that he commits to a project and this is
super technical and just like really
gets involved and
can do can execute very well in a number
of genres so
i was just like talking to him and i was
like hey i
i got these songs that i've been writing
um
what would it look like if you recorded
and produced them
and of course he was like i love this
idea and so
getting someone else involved
in the project yeah that lights a fire
and then you begin moving forward and
it's and it moves from just being a
hobby and a pastime to being
production this is good this is going to
be a thing again
from a timeline standpoint i made that
commitment last year so that was 2021
i was talking to him about it like the
middle of the year and i was like i
don't know when this is going to come
out probably 2023 that's what i told him
i was like i don't want you to
prioritize this i cannot prioritize this
because i can't work on this
because i'm
it is very very busy have a lot of other
things going on this is a nights and
weekends thing for me and and if you
want it to be a nights and weekends
thing for you then i was like don't stop
working on something to work on my thing
but if you i'll send you things as i
have them send you demos and then so
that was kind of the process
uh but he would like turn something
around and like i'd be like man that's
you know that's a lot better than my
demo
you know
um
and
i kind of got addicted to the process
start and i was like well why am i doing
i'm gonna do six songs i got more songs
and i was like there's a lot of
different the re the thing that sent me
to 11 songs was trying to cover the
breadth of the experience
i was like well there's this other
aspect that i really want to talk about
and then i was like um
also i kind of feel that there needs to
be like a thesis
statement that is sort of the beginning
of the album is the first song
which is the first single
and that's believe me which was one of
those was written pretty late in the
process because it was stepping back and
looking at what i had done and thinking
about uh this would be a good thesis
statement a good opener to where i'm
going to kind of take you through
conceptually on on the album
um and so that's how i ended up getting
to 11 songs okay um and the last thing
i'll talk about before we actually
listen to the single
um
is why it's called james and the shame
right why is it not rhett mclaughlin
so
at some point early on i had this idea
that what if this was like a covert
thing that i didn't even talk about but
i just put out there
and then i started thinking about the
fact that so much of
if if the whole point of this thing is
to connect with people who are
experiencing something similar or can
relate
well one of the things that has been
such a um
has brought those people out of the
woodwork is me sharing these things
through
um
the public forum that i have as the
public person that i am yeah
and so i was like it doesn't make sense
to not talk about it or try to make it
seem like there's just some new country
guy who's talking about spiritual things
and if you want to know about it you can
uh but i was like but i don't want it to
be
rhett mclaughlin
i don't want to call i don't want it to
be my name
i want it to be something that is like
hey this is something outside of
everything else that this guy does when
you hear the name rep mclaughlin
you think
rhett and link comedy
i'm not supposed to take this seriously
where when is the joke when was the
first punch line coming in this song
right
um
and also
it's it becomes pretty obvious pretty
quick and i didn't want it to be a
distraction for somebody who stumbles
across it uh in a playlist or something
on spotify to be like mclaughlin
if if if what i have put out into the
world professionally which is a bunch of
light-hearted silly stuff to take your
mind off things isn't your cup of tea i
don't want you to not want to listen to
this if this would actually be something
you'd be into so yeah that's where um
james and the shame came from
james and the shame not only
does it rhyme does it kind of roll off
the tongue
but again shame is the dominant
sort of emotion of the enneagram three
of someone who is performance minded
so the the
the twos the threes and the fours in the
enneagram are all in the heart
triad
uh and
that means that there's a whole lot
going on in here that they
try to deal with in certain ways and the
way the three deals with their shame is
to try to keep performing for you don't
you just don't just keep watching watch
me do cool things and you won't have to
know who i really am and who i'm ashamed
of
and so
that whole idea of james and the shame
it's like obviously
the shame is too means two things number
one this was not a
it is a solo project i wrote
all of the music and all of the lyrics
but the final production includes some
other very talented musicians who play
different instruments and so i guess in
some ways that represents the other
people who collaborated to make these
final products
but also
more so than that it's the shame that
follows me around wherever i go it's
like you got james you got the shame too
but let's let's listen to this song man
okay but but first let's do a quick plug
all right uh
stevie's podcast comes back
we want to show some love to best
friends back all right her and the game
they their friendship is
blossomed it's happened
and now they're branching out into other
things i'm told
that they're going to be
getting nagin's sister who's a
gynecologist
on an episode yeah so it's
you know i can always learn stuff from a
guy to college they're not just talking
about
you know their high school days now now
that they've rekindled the friendship
they're moving into the things they want
to talk about so check out best friends
back all right wherever get your podcast
season two it's out now
it's happening
turn it they're turning another corner
another corner
all right you ready to play this thing
yes okay so this is i've i've when you
played it for me
i listen to it i think three times in a
row and then at a different occasion i
heard it again i've only heard this song
four times and i've only heard another
song
once
there's only three songs that are
mastered right now
um okay
but yes i'm told there is an album i
just don't know so this is the first
single it's called believe me it was
released on friday the 15th so you can
go to wherever you listen to music to
listen to it but we're gonna play it
right now as well
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think you want an answer
i'm not prepared to give
[Music]
must be something that i want
[Music]
fame and fortune or at least
[Music]
it may seem too
cut and dry
but i just found some things i could not
brush aside
[Music]
now if you love life
i don't think it's true
[Music]
i'm not asking you
to agree i'm just asking you
to believe
[Music]
that might say
more about you
[Music]
i know it should
[Music]
if you take my word
when i say i
didn't leave cause i wasn't
[Music]
but there goes my pride
with this refrain that i be seen as
justified
[Music]
likely nothing
i could say
and i'm not sure you would care for me
to explain
sure you can pray
but i don't think it's true
[Music]
i'm not asking you
to agree i'm just asking you
to believe
me
[Music]
you say my heart
was never true
that might say
more about you
[Music]
i love it man the first time you played
this song for me i was blown away like i
don't know what the look on my face was
but you started smiling really early i
mean yeah right right at the beginning
because like you know i'm a sound guy
before a lyric guy
right and so
i was just relieved that it was really
good
what did you think was what what it was
going to be because i cuz i was telling
you about it but i was purple and this
is we can kind of start getting into the
dynamic of like how me and you related
about this because well i i was very
much i didn't want
i wanted to have something to show you
well that was done
i think that was
i'm glad that
i didn't i didn't hear anything
i mean hearing what
you just played is the first thing that
i heard of it right specifically no
demos no no sneak peeks no nothing right
um
but i mean the the production i mean i
knew derek was great and i knew he was
going to do something great with it and
you had told me that he was
hooking you up with
like studio musicians
some in nashville some in la right that
were like adding
they were adding i mean it wasn't you
know they were adding their stuff and
sending it in
yeah well so um
not now we thought we were going to go
nashville because we knew we needed a
pedal steel
but then he was like hey i got uh
this guy i know alex strawl
uh who's who's in la
and yeah he's like a
multi-instrumentalist
and he can play
a mean electric guitar but he also can
play the pedal still he can play the
mandolin he can play the banjo this dude
can play anything with strings
and um so
that pedal steel is alex's like
it was like it was passed down to him
he's got all these instruments that were
passed down to him that are so great
such a great move to having has that
like old school
feel which was very important i mean
this song
i mean i it definitely has this kind of
lord huron vibe which i absolutely love
and then so like from a production
instrumentation standpoint
and it
having heard another song from the album
i know that it it doesn't just stay
squarely in this place which is also
exciting
but so i'm just talking about this song
not the album
or the other song i've heard
um but that's true that is true
the album
in itself that this is there was a
reason that this was again i wrote this
song
after i had written almost every song i
think i only wrote one more song after
this one so it's more and it was like
i want this to be
the thematic and conceptual
introduction to what the album is about
which we can get into in a second
but
probably more important
getting to what you're saying is
i want this to be assigned to people who
care about this type of music that this
is a serious endeavor in it yeah mission
accomplished i think it's it's
it sounds great i mean it's definitely
something that if i stumbled on this
song i would be like
what the hell i'd have to send it to you
you sent it to me right then again
that's that was the thinking so that's
something that we would be in terms of a
genre like
indie
western
folk
like which that lord huron pocket
there's not you know there's other
people doing it but they're they're my
favorite
um
and so i didn't say the word country but
then
your vocals come in and i'm like oh [ __ ]
the first thing i thought with the very
beginning of this one and i don't you
know i don't like drawing comparisons
but
uh i was like this is this is a 90s
country vocal delivery
i def
like in the opening line i was like i
hear
alan jackson and i'm like i knew neither
one of us are huge fans of alan jackson
but he's so squarely
90s country
vocal that like
and something about your tone
and the melody of that first line just
evoked that not a specific song but him
as an artist right and then the whole
song is not an allen jackson thing it it
actually it goes very much into okay
this is
this is a really good choice it's a
really strong choice
you know for you to
say i'm gonna sing as a country i'm
gonna sing country
i'm gonna sing country vocals
and the juxtaposition of that over the
production is really cool
and it's
i mean it's it's not a sturgeon simpson
thing which like some people might try
to draw that comparison or whatever
because the vocals are so 90s
that i i just think that it's like
a really strong smart it's i almost said
fun choice but like yeah it's exciting
it excites me because i feel like it
makes it more
unique there's there's people i'm not
following country music that closely
right now
um but i know that like the
the 90s movement that happens in fashion
it's happening in country music there's
like current stars you played a song for
me of a current
up-and-comer who then played a song that
was like very nineties intentionally
um
you talking about what luke comes doing
the brooks and dunn thing oh yeah that
was it luke combs
um so i love that i love this song
in terms of how it melts those things
together
and then
you know the
i'm a melody guy right so like i really
like that
kind of slinky
it's kind of a sly
melody what key is it in
uh that song is in
g
i love g
i don't know
uh there's something something about the
melody line of the verse
it's like
uh
i love it well it's funny because you
know
again
very little of this was
calculated right so but you had to make
a choice to sing [ __ ] what no so
basically so this is how that happened
right
so with that first song that i wrote
that the the old letter song
if you take the accent off of the
out of the lyrics and then i don't sing
with an accent
um
then you would be like okay this could
be like
gregory allen izakov like folk but your
demo had the country inflection
oh yeah yeah yeah so so from the get-go
you were just singing country you're
writing a country song well i'm talking
about the old the old letter song yeah
the demo the first demo you recorded
yeah yeah but
yeah but i made the decision i was like
first of all there's a little bit of
country in just the way that i talk and
so there's a little bit of country in
the way that i sing
but you know how you you usually
translate and you make a different
decision like i'm trying to embody a
certain character or whatever and yeah
you got you got to have a sound
and so
because that's what we do i mean it's
something that we very calculated to say
okay
i don't want to sound like well weird al
in this song first i don't want to sound
like a redneck that was such that was
one of the craziest things in in in
recording
is that in making the decision to be
like how do i deliver this is
me and you have recorded so much music
in so many different genres it's like
okay this is a wrap this is a country
song this is a hair metal song and we
always just adapt to whatever the genre
is and we're very good chameleons
that then you have to be like well i
gotta that's what every artist is
ultimately doing they're like adopting
you know
you love cocaine and rhinestones and now
i've gotten into it and it's fascinating
hearing all the stories about george
jones trying to figure out how to sound
like george jones right and you find
yourself doing impersonations of other
people oh i really i'm i'm trying to
sound like the avett brothers there
without thinking about it and it's
there's an exercise of trusting yourself
to be like no
i don't have to like try to sound like
anyone and so what is the natural melody
and the natural intonation and
expression that comes from me it is a
culmination of all the music that i've
consumed and sung along with all those
years and that's why when i started
singing country
so much
90s melodies come out because
that was when i was coming of age and
it's a safe choice i feel like in terms
of like if you're
if you're gonna get a comparison if
you're gonna get analyzed
it's an exciting choice
so i'm really glad you made it it's not
you know there's no i guess what i'm
saying
people might okay because it's like when
you started saying 90s and derek started
saying 90s i was like you know what
you're right
i was just like i want this track to
sound as old school as i can
uh it's got in terms of chord structure
it gets into a little more it's almost
like it gets into like roy orbison yeah
type you know because that's that's what
i was really good at sort of the key
question the seventh kind of drop
love there's seventh all over this album
that's it that's what i was trying to
get at with the g and that's not
something that you hear a lot in just
your average country song yeah right and
so
and then there you know it's got that
and then gunner who who who did the
percussion for this
uh is like an incredible incredible
musician
uh kind of
brought in that like shuffly rhythm
which is not when i write it when i send
a demo over it's me and a guitar
yeah like and the wood block stuff and
yeah right um so anyway
those choices as you'll and we're going
to talk we'll do another podcast in the
fall once the whole thing's out to kind
of talk more about the music but like
the ultimately what i'll say at this
point is that
it was calculated to a degree but most
of it was just like what do i naturally
hear in this and what sounds good to me
and how do i want to sing this naturally
with this much with this little sort of
acting attached to it yeah as possible
and it turns out that that is
sort of this mix of old school and 90s
country
and then lyrically
you know i'm not asking to you to agree
i'm just asking you to believe me you
know and then i mean it's very
it it suits country because it's kind of
matter of fact you know yeah it's very
simple um you know there's a sincere
it's it's there it's not
you know you can really read into your
experience because it's kind of on the
page in a lot of ways but it's i'm not
saying that as a critique i think that
fits country music really well and i
think it also just even though i don't
by the way i wouldn't call it
a country album i mean based on this
song so it's like that's the i don't
know where the what i'm going to call
the album
but well that's the that's the genre
that i checked in the in the one in the
distribution box because it's yeah
that's good that's only the only one you
can check yeah that makes sense and then
maybe like americana yeah as a secondary
genre so lyrically
i mean you're really putting yourself
out there it's not
this song is not veiled
very few of them are and so and i think
that comes from the fact that it's like
all right sure you can pray i like
that's the first time i heard that lie
you know and i i know your experience
but i just think it's
i mean i obviously relate to it so much
so i just think it's
it's nice i do think that people
having shared our deconstruction stories
i do think that this
will be
a source of comfort
to people
absolutely like that's
uh
that's powerful you know it's i mean i
the the conversations that we've had at
this table about
our spiritual journeys
you know i i've just been blown away by
how it's helped people
and so
it's so cool that and this is going to
do that too and it's going to do it in a
way that
it's going to do it in a different way
you know it
music is so powerful
it's powerful in a totally different
way than podcasts
that is
i keep saying exciting but that's just
what i keep going back to is that like
you know i'm just celebrating the fact
that you're putting yourself out there
you had enough experience to know that
like how much of a risk did this feel
like for you and on what area because
when you the little the
this song at least is something that
you've already said a number of times i
feel like so where is the where is the
risk
where's the fear
well i mean i think there's a there's
it doesn't stay this tame
you know there are some there are some
what you might call angry songs where
i'm just letting my emotions in the way
i feel about you are you at church not
really yelling
uh
in hypocrisy that i that i see and those
things that get me kind of worked up but
garth brooks yelled in shameless he did
i was hamless yeah and i don't want any
chris gaines comparisons
i didn't say it um well so i think that
there's a little bit of that but i think
chris
people know where i stand
um
i
i guess it is it is you know every once
in a while i toss a little bomb out into
the pond
uh you know whatever the analogy that's
not a good one uh i stir things up i
kick the hornets nest a little bit for
those people who care to to to feel
offended by the things that i say
um is it let me ask you so it does it's
going to stir that up a little bit do
you
have you felt like it was a bigger risk
creatively to like put yourself out
there
um as
by doing this project then
which
or is it what you're saying in the
lyrics is it the message that you're
getting across because
there's a there's a creative risk
involved in saying hey i'm
i'm one half of rent and link this is
what you know me for i'm a comedian
you know it's like there's a
if it were me i would have to get over
this
hurdle of like
embarrassment that would be like you
know
is there risk there is there fear there
has that been part of this
you know
for better or for worse
i
i just always approach things just
believing that i'm going to find some
way to pull them off
and and it's probably
it's probably a
misguided self-confidence that yes i can
do this and i can make an album that i
would actually if i were not myself
enjoy and like
well i'm not embarrassed for you now
that i've heard it
i'll say that
but i mean i guess so yeah that moment
when you're like for the first time
here and on gmm when you're saying i've
released a country music
you know
there's a little there's
album there is there a sheepishness
there like i think from a creative
standpoint when
one of the things you're most well known
for is like being on your knees and
having your best friend pee chocolate
into your mouth from a fountain that is
next to his penis
i just don't think there's a lot of
things you can do to creatively
embarrass yourself
honestly and in one sense i think that
gets into one of the
sort of unrealized motivations to do
something like this
is you know me i talk about it all the
time is that i do have this chip on my
shoulder creatively you know
there's lots of things that we want to
do collectively to show people
what we are capable of creatively and i
think there's always an element of that
in everything that i do and so
i can't i'm not going to be dishonest
with you and tell you that
i believe in what i've created here and
i think it's good and i think other
people will agree
and i and there's a part of my ego that
wants you to agree
um okay well then i've stroked your ego
enough but i also think i'm projecting
i guess in that if i were in your shoes
that's how i would feel so instead
i think it's you know i think it's
it's something that's um
inspiring about the fact that you have
this like
this
this confidence
yeah maybe it comes from a chip on your
shoulder or whatever but like you you
want to express yourself in this way and
you go for it and that's something that
uh you know i could do more of
you know so if i am to make this about
me for a second
uh i do feel like
it's like oh i would
i would be embarrassed at every turn you
know even the thing about talking about
like being a dj i had to make a decision
to say you know this is kind of a
this is not some you know i had to
decide what my
um
uh what my
posture was gonna be about it right you
know it's like yeah this is something
that i'm into uh
and i'm not gonna be sheepish or
apologetic or embarrassed
by
having some sort of
you know creative outlet or aspirations
so
uh i think that's where that question
was coming from it's more about me than
you but uh no but i i have thought about
it because the worst case scenario is
people are like this youtube guy thinks
he's a musician now
who cares right okay i've lost nothing
you know if you already see me as that
if you see me as this youtube guy this
hack
that just stumbled into fame
and isn't really talented then nothing
if you already think that then you
thinking that again is not a problem for
me you know what i'm you know what i'm
saying yeah
so
what is the
is there bigger there's bigger risks
uh content-wise in other songs yeah it
gets more it gets more explicit
literally there's a few f-bombs dropped
on the album you know to to to you know
to give a hint of that are you nervous
about any of any of the specifics coming
out i mean what no where'd you
i'm not no no i didn't i mean you wrote
a you said you wrote a song to your kids
you wrote a song to your parents um
well
yeah i uh
the i you know
i don't know how much i want to talk
about the i mean
i have a great relationship with my
parents but the thing that i am
conscious of is that
because they are still very much strong
christians and i'm very much a public
figure who has stated that i am not and
i'm critical of christianity that makes
their life more difficult than i would
like it to be right
um
because of the way people in the church
are you know uh and so and just the way
people in general are not seeing a lot
of people in the church it's just
if somebody that you're related to is
talking about what you're all into then
they become a little bit of a scapegoat
and i and and so you know i i i'm
sensitive to that that's in some ways
that's kind of what the song to them is
about
um well we can leave it leave that part
at that because i i do think i would
like to i'm going to hear the whole
album at some point and then if we can
kind of i'm sure we're revisiting this
yeah yeah but you know
in terms of when we started talking
about it i was trying to remember when
that was do you remember because i think
there were like hints
of
i'm writing some song i'm writing some
songs i don't remem i i just remember
the first time it kind of registered
was
maybe you had mentioned it a few times
but you had mentioned in ep
i think that's the first time i was like
what
you just you're gonna okay so you're
you're not just writing songs you're
you're gonna release songs
you know like
um
what
what what were you thinking there
because again it's like
it
what you just told
everybody for the you know for the past
hour
is not was not the entry point for our
conversation we never sat down
and you said you know
hey i'm you gave me this whole story
so to me
my experience was
oh he's doing this thing he doesn't want
to talk about
but then he feels like he needs he
apparently it's gaining momentum because
he's talking about making an ep so now
he's mentioning it to me and i respect
like i have an appreciation for it now
given what you said it was like it's a
deeply personal exercise
that is an uh
uh
an application of therapy
that then you would obviously talk to
jesse about
you know in the same way that there's
plenty of stuff
in my personal journey in my heart in my
therapy sessions that
i process myself first of all and then
there's thing there's much of that
that um
the vast vast majority that i'll bring
that christie and i will discuss and
i'll bring her into and then
you know so i recognize that then
there's certain things at certain times
that i'll bring you into it and it's not
even a calculation of i'm keeping things
from you it's just that like you know
there's only so many hours in a day and
even though we spend the majority of
them together we're always occupied with
the things that we're doing jesse asks
me multiple times a week did you talk a
link about so-and-so i'm like baby
i
no because we talked about every other
thing you know what i'm saying like but
because we're constantly i recognize all
that
yeah but my experience with it was you
know
you know it was just
a little a little thing here a little
thing there an ep
an album
uh
and
so i'm like
without having the full story
i think there was a lot of
well i'm just left to like okay how am i
going to respond to this
yeah and again
none of that was calculated i mean i if
i think back and try to figure out why
that was the way that it happened
i think there is a part of my there's a
part of me that believes and this is
just
kind of the way my brain works is like
sometimes
talking about something the only thing
that is good that comes from talking
about something is talking yourself out
of it
and so i don't like to talk a lot about
things i just like to keep doing them
so you're saying if you would have
talked to me about it
you would have talked yourself out of it
i think that i think that not again i
haven't thought about this at all but i
think that there's a there there's a
fear
that like because this doesn't make any
sense because i don't have time for this
because this is not necessarily a good
business decision
if we start talking about it
to then like talk about it from a
strategic standpoint or a positioning
standpoint it may just
float away as it may just not be a
priority but for me it was like this is
a this is a personal thing that i'm like
i'm revisiting on my own time it was up
until very very recently i never did any
of this during work hours those past
couple of months there's been a couple
of days where i'll be like i have to go
record this or i have to do that
that's kind of gotten into my regular
schedule but
because it was very much something that
i just kept pushing forward
in my free time so to speak free time
air quotes
um
i think it was
there was just this unspoken i don't
want to sit down and have a real serious
conversation about this because i don't
want to slow it down
because
it's gaining so much momentum personally
not that i thought that if you would
talk me out of it that's not really what
i'm saying but i hear you saying that if
we talked about it it would very quickly
get to like
you know um
what is the
what is the feasibility of this there's
not you know there's not
there's not a lot of positives to it in
terms of like
mythical unless you're really talking
about i want to do this as a solo artist
and this you know if it became some
mythical endeavor from a business
standpoint there's a lot more questions
that all feel like roadblocks to this
personal project if we had that
conversation and that's why i did that's
why i took a long time i didn't talk to
anyone here about it for the longest
time for the same reasons because like
guys
you may interpret this as a selfish act
if i start talking about it and you're
like well we're also working so busy and
you're all for making your little
your little album so you know what i'm
saying yeah you didn't bring it up
because
it could be uh
it could be perceived as like a threat
to
the business
yeah now i firmly believe that it is not
and i have a lot of reasons for
believing that it's not i mean i i think
that
the way i kind of analyze
that is
it's funny because what we have
is
incredibly unusual
they're i actually can't think of a
entertainment duo where they're but both
people are qualified entertainers
and
literally every expression of that is in
is only in the context of that almost
every duo that there's an example of is
just like oh yeah and he does his little
thing his little side hobby thing it's
like super common right
and but then all but the main thing they
do is the stuff that they do together i
always thought that
the reason that that hadn't been the
case up until now
is twofold number one it's like we just
never have time for anything and number
two it just never it never i never had
an idea that it made sense to go and do
by myself until this so it isn't like
i've been sitting around
thinking
i find it unusual that we haven't done
anything solo independently of each
other for this for all these years
but i also find it oh it kind of makes
sense because
we there hasn't been neither of us have
had something where it's just like i've
got to get this into the world this is
the first thing that came along
to me it doesn't feel like a threat to
what we have if anything
it feels like because it's not a
replacement
of anything that we're doing well
in some ways it feels like another facet
to
the red side of rhett and link
do you know what i'm you know what i'm
getting at yeah i think that there was
so was the
was this a
a threat to the to the business strategy
of what we're doing but then there's
another part that's like if i bring this
up
would it
will it will will it be will link
perceive it as a threat to
their
to our creative partnership
and i thought that
or
more or our friendship i don't know well
and again
while it wasn't calculated if you were
to ask me like okay well all right that
we're going to have to have a really
long conversation about this that is
going to again i didn't think this
but i may have been thinking it
subconsciously it's just like okay
if we have a conversation about this at
a really early stage
it may really just get bogged down
you know because now in my mind what
went from being this
this thing that was gaining momentum
it's so difficult to get things to
happen and bring things into the world
you we know that right
and
when i
subconsciously perceive that there might
be a conversation or some point that
becomes a point of impasse
i'm like i don't want to have that i
don't want to i don't want to do that
like let's let this actually begin to
become something and then we can have a
conversation about it versus having a
conversation about it a year ago
you know
not that we didn't talk about it not
that you didn't know about it but it
wasn't like hey let's sit down and
literally hash this thing out because in
some ways the other part of my brain was
thinking there's nothing to hash out
like i'm doing this thing
if you were doing this thing
i'd be like that's awesome that's cool
man
do it now if suddenly we can't do
something that we want to do because
you're doing this then we can have a
conversation but if that's not the case
just keep going you know if it's make if
it's making you a better more fulfilled
person then that makes you a better more
fulfilled comedy partner business
partner and friend
if you're pursuing your passion and
doing something that's bringing you joy
in life
so i think that that that's my that's
how i feel about it honestly that's why
i feel like it's a a healthy thing for
me and ultimately for us
because
anything that's healthy for me is
healthy for us and vice versa
anything that's helpful for you is
helpful for uh is healthy for us
yeah when i i mean when i hear that i'm
like is that true there has to be an
exception to that rule right it's like
that just can't is it could that just be
true across the board you know i
actually that's my
gut reaction to that statement i think
that you know
my preference would have been to talk
about it earlier
but i think it's again this is more
about me than it is about you it's not
like
uh
so
i have because i think that that's true
because there's
you know the
yeah it's like if i hear you're making
an ep or doing this thing the first
thing i'm going to think is the first
thing i did think was not
i'm so excited for you i want to
celebrate this it's like what does this
mean for us yeah you know
um and it taps into
some insecurity and you know i know that
there's um
you know i don't want to over blow this
whole abandonment issue thing but
that's it's there right so it's
you know i
that's part of my process
but
i mean we had had conversations about
this
related to other stuff
so i
actually this project didn't bring this
to
a head
as much as like
when you i don't we don't have to get
into the details of it but
my response to
this project this album of yours
um
was shaped by the experience that we had
on ronstat
you know because that was
the genesis of that project was messy
right like literally like the first
email and slacks and stuff that was
going around about analyzing the
opportunity to to partner
um and work on ronstein and be attached
to it
you know the way that that the way that
that started was just
messy and it was something that then
you know there were
we had to work through it right well and
meaning that
when
when we were first approached about that
the ask was can rhett play ronstead
which was not a thing that we had
like we don't right we don't go out
pursuing opportunities now we may do we
both we don't haven't done a lot lately
but we both audition for roles that if
we were to
we'll never we'll never get one but we
do it kind of for fun and maybe one
would come and we would oh you're link's
going to be on this show or elaine's
going to make a guest appearance and
he's not going in as rhett in the link
is going in his link and vice versa so
that's been a conversation but that was
being brought into mythical as a
mythical project be like oh mythical's
going to
help produce this
but the ask was for rhett to play
ronstadt and so how do what do we how do
we make this a red and link thing and
that became the conversation as opposed
to oh it's going to be a mythical thing
that red is doing yeah but the way and
then the way that it became a
conversation was just not smooth
you know yeah that we would we we've
talked about it and we
have learned that
we would have done things differently
right yeah so i don't want to you know i
just feel like that gives context to
this because i feel like
by moving through that and growing
through that we were able to articulate
um
our desires like you were able to
articulate some of your desires for
well you know it's
d let's
do we have to do every single thing
together
you know we started having conversations
about this i think there's a whole other
podcast in here i'm just going to allude
to it and then
yeah and then i'm bringing to the table
well you know very early on we made this
choice that we weren't gonna everything
we're gonna do we're gonna do together
so it's like okay now are we revisiting
that
and what does that mean and how far does
that go well it turns out
it's still
it it's not that drastic it's just that
because of
my makeup and what i'm bringing to the
table
it's it's scarier for me and i think
there is a you know in me giving off
that energy i think when it comes around
to this project
i mean you're probably gonna have this
sense that i'm gonna be more concerned
about it than excited first
but
we we benefited from going through uh
and
you know getting on the same page on the
ronstat project getting on the same page
about
um
just our approach to things that
mythical and how you know there's so
much in this that i just
i know i'm flirting with it
but i guess the point i'm making right
now is that
we really had a series of good
conversations that
got us more on the
same page
you know having
the mantra of saying when in doubt talk
it out
you know is is something that we really
benefited from
so when
and ironically a lot of you doing the
songwriting stuff was happening in
parallel to all this but when it came to
a point of you were ready to talk about
it then i was in a much better place to
receive it
um
and and that was even without the
benefit of the entire backstory that you
just shared like the the personal
process of it
but
seeing it as
like
not seeing it as a threat to what we're
doing is something that i can say
with
to to the 98th degree
that i can you know and that's saying
and i do think that it's
if it hasn't been obvious up until this
point
so
this is not me saying that i want to go
and be a full-time musician
right i'm not touring
i don't have time to tour
even if i wanted to go around playing
these songs
uh i'm not saying i'll never play these
songs for someone for a for a crowd i'm
just saying that that's not the
intention isn't like now i'm a musician
and that's what i do it's more like hey
this has always been a
a very much a hobby of mine and it'll be
cool to have this sort of ongoing thing
because i expect to release more music
because it's like hey i wrote a song
let's record it let's release it it's
something that i can responsibly fit
into my schedule and not drop the ball
with what we're doing here but just so
just
that this isn't like i'm going to pursue
a career as a musician and that's what i
do it's more like well i was already a
musician and now i'm releasing some
music that is just mine
um yeah and i also started to realize
that over the course of the pandemic
i you know when i started the listening
party broadcast on instagram
you know to like take my personal
creative outlet of like listening to
music making playlists and turn that
into something that
involved
our audience
you know it was something that i didn't
calculate and then at the moments when i
talked to you about it i had that
sheepish like this is not really a thing
because it
first of all it wasn't but i felt like
we didn't have like just a clear
conversation about it it was more like
yeah i'm doing this thing it'll be fun
oh i'm gonna do 21 of these you know as
it turns out and
i think
you're different than me in that i do
think you were more inclined to be
encouraging about it because
of what because you were doing other
stuff to you saw a parallel
i mean did you
um i mean i
i see a parallel now and that's helpful
for me i guess i guess ultimately what
i'll say is that like
a lot of these things don't cross my
mind unless someone else brings them up
okay you know
it's just my my disposition is different
and so
like i haven't thought about the fact
that you're also doing your own podcast
right and you know what you've seen that
doesn't hurt my feelings because i know
you yeah but i think there was a point
when it could have hurt my feelings
and it might have just been two years
three years ago you're saying the fact
that it doesn't cross my mind that
you're doing it yeah because it's like
right
yeah because
because you're like well i would care if
you were doing a podcast exactly right
right
yeah and i think i just i think
ultimately
for me it's like
i just have
i know that we both have so many
independent interests and desires and
things that we want to do and accomplish
that
if those things can can happen and not
sacrifice all the things that we want to
do together
then
that's a beautiful thing i mean these
things are this is different because
your podcast with your dad is a mythical
production well i was talking about the
listening party yeah which i think
the thing that's the same is also like
me saying oh you know what i'm gonna
i'll i i'm pursuing the skill of being a
dj if that means i'm gonna actually get
a gig being a dj somewhere sometime
you know on my own time
i'm sure it'd be something that you
would celebrate and you wouldn't think
twice about it in the way that i might
have thought twice about your album
because it's just like it's a hobby as
an outlet it's a side project that
who knows still might lead to something
you know i do think we can talk about
that but the thing about
the like
just to put a finer point on me and
being inspired by your exercise is that
in a way that we're different like i
haven't given myself permission like you
say we both have the all these
aspirations but we do not have them to
the same level and that's something that
uh i i am drawing inspiration from that
i could grow in that area like the
podcast with my dad
is is is a great outlet like it's it's
been a highlight of my week whenever we
get together and and and do it it's a
creative outlet it is part of mythical
it's something that we're doing that you
know
we split it down the middle
you know well
but
it wasn't my idea
you know
as far as i can recall it was stevie's
idea and i was like
well this sounds like a great idea that
i'm never going to do is was my first
reaction and then when she kept talking
about it definitely you you then my next
reaction was this still sounds like a
decent idea that i'm never going to do
you had to be kind of dragged into it
yeah
and even
you know it's like when even once my dad
was on board and it was happening
like i was like
this isn't really we're not really going
to do this it's like i didn't give
myself permission to say
do i want to do this
or i do want to do this
and it might fail we might fall flat on
our face but i'm going to do it because
i'm excited about it
you know that's a
i think
your encouragement and
like following this journey for you has
been
it's it's gotten me it's gotten me off
the dime a little bit
um
not in a oh [ __ ] if he's gonna do
something i gotta do something but
actually in a creative outlet
um
just tapping into my desires kind of way
in in like a
mostly pure motive kind of way you know
it's not like a tip for tat thing so i'm
actually
like listening to that song and like
being able to celebrate it and celebrate
what's happening with this project
is
is something that i'm proud of for me so
it's you know it's not something that
i'm conjuring anymore out of some sense
of obligation
right well and to clarify
the james and the shame project is not a
part of mythical but the reason that
it's not a part of mythical is because i
did not want to make anyone
here have to work on it
kara
our personal assistant has been helping
but beyond that
very few people have been involved in
every single expense has come out of my
pocket which i am reasonably certain i
will not make money from this project
yeah you didn't want me to lose money
but then hey if this gets wildly
successful like i mean you probably
gonna have to cut me in somehow
we'll have to talk about it yeah so that
that's the only reason it's and it's
also this is not a core
a funny podcast with your dad is a is a
part of the core sort of focus of
mythical a serious country album about
deconstruction is not part of the core
mission of mythical so
there's a number of reasons that it's
not a mythical thing and that also is
one of the reasons that i don't really
work on it here or with the people at
this company and i work on it outside of
my normal responsibilities here
um but we're at we're at a point in our
career when we can do things that are
associated with our careers
that don't involve the other person but
can but will be a part of mythical
of course like so dispatchers from
myrtle beach is
an a great example of that yeah and i
mean
you know there may be other things there
should be other things well so one of
the things we haven't talked about i
know we're going a little bit long but
it's fine
um
i think that there i mean i interest i'm
interested how you feel about dispatches
from myrtle beach
in regards to this because
one of the things first of all
i get so creatively frustrated because
as much as we put out into the world
there's a lot more that doesn't make it
out into the world because of
limitations because
we're we're conceptualizing things that
need to be green lit by people and they
need to be financed and they have to go
through pitch meetings et cetera et
cetera and some of the ideas that
i'm most passionate about
that i feel are most representative of
us creatively are things that we can't
just put out on youtube for free
they have to be financed and it's a
different model
and
very few of those things have
made it to the to to where people can
enjoy them yeah with music it's
no one else like if i can get somebody
to i don't even have to get somebody to
produce it like i could just record it
you know at the creative house and
release it like it
and you can just go through spotify or
what you just get distribute your music
there's been something so freeing and
life-giving
in
just something happening like having an
idea and then it can just be birthed and
given to the world
but part of that has been and yep
doing it independently
in it not being a collaborative thing
to me
there's been it's made me appreciate the
things that are collaborative
um
and i've also just
hey
this is on me like i gotta finish this i
have to be the one to make the call
i've got to make these decisions and
move this forward and then also like do
a bunch of things that i haven't done
in years like i did the
i designed the artwork for the
for the first single i don't design
artwork yeah i was very surprised but i
was like i don't want i don't want to
pay somebody else i'm paying so many
people to do so many parts of this
i don't want to pay somebody else to do
this it feels like i can figure this out
but there's been something very
rewarding about just conceptualizing and
executing something and putting it onto
the world on my own i haven't done that
in so long
yeah there's been something personally
rewarding
in doing that not because it's like oh
finally i get to do something on my own
it's just like oh no i made a decision
to do this on my own
and it's been life-giving
in a different way than a collaboration
yeah um
i think that fans
of ours mythical beasts will ask
yeah but i mean white i mean there's
backup there's
harmony
why didn't you get him to sing some why
are you gonna sing some harmony on that
you know and that was that that was very
specifically a calculated decision
talk about that um
because we haven't talked about that but
i
i'm reading between the lines and i i
yeah because when
i sing melody and you sing harmony
that's a written link song
that's
that's a rhett and link song
this isn't a written link project
and i don't want people to
think that it it needs to be its own
thing
right it doesn't need to be like oh rent
link also made a country album right no
no it's not a retin-link thing it's a
red thing and that's okay and and you
know what that that's good
is what i'm saying
um
sure you would have been great at it um
you know i think that
but but even even from a sonic's
standpoint i want it to feel like its
own thing me and you singing together is
a very specific great and beautiful
thing but it's a rat and length thing i
don't want to take the rhett and link
thing and spread it over into this
that cheapens the rhett and link thing
and it cheapens the james and the shame
thing
you know and so
i want this to have a signature sound so
like in that song that we listened to
today that's derek singing he's great
vocalist that's him singing the the the
backup lyrics but there are songs where
i sing my own harmony when when it makes
sense thematically their songs were
jesse
sings harmony where it makes sense
thematically
um
but the thing that
if i had a song about you on the album
then it makes sense for you know what
i'm saying then it would make sense for
you to to
to sing the song it was like
to me it was about theme unless it's
about me being dead
and standing on its own and it was like
hey like
i
to at one point it became almost out of
principle
like
i don't want link to hear this until
it's done
because
it's not a rhetoric thing not out of
spite but because of all the reasons
that we've just covered and it's like i
don't want to complicate that i don't
want to complicate that and muddy that
if it really is a rhett thing then let
it be a red thing
and something that then i can just kind
of present to you and you can enjoy
and honestly i've been treating
dispatchers from myrtle beach the exact
same way like i haven't
i i
am at the time that we're recording this
where the first episode's about to drop
and that's when i'm going to listen to
it for the first time i'm going to
listen to it as a
fan
of listening to you and your dad talk
not as somebody who's a producer and
it's gonna be like well let me give you
some feedback on that
you know what i'm saying yeah and to me
there's something healthy about that
separation
i respect that i understand that
um
is there anything else that you wanted
to share
um
i don't think so i mean obviously i'll
i'll use this time to say that
i am genuinely interested in a lot of
people hearing this
um so it gets to the people who it will
impact in the way that i would like to
see them impacted
so
do all the things that you do with the
musicians that you like
you know
listen to it
follow me on those places i'm not i am
creating like
i think you should refer to you refer to
in third person i i'm creating james and
the shame profiles in different places
but only as placeholders so people don't
steal them but all updates about this
are going to come through all my initial
social channels so you can go like
follow those pla those those accounts
over there just so that somebody will be
following them but it's primarily going
to just be done through all my stuff
but
i i would like
it would do nothing
i would it would do my heart very very
well for somebody out there who likes
this kind the only reason they're
listening
to what i'm doing is because they like
the music
and then they're like this isn't this
guy's not singing about the stuff that i
typically listen to in country music
this guy seems to be
challenging it would be cool if they
developed a
life of its own yeah and so and and that
again is is
that's my desire is that this thing has
a has a home
in people who
will relate to the story that i that i'm
telling and so if you think you know
somebody who is like i've never sent
anything to this person because i know
they're not going to like x y and z that
these guys have done if you're like oh
they might he might they might like this
send it to him so that's what i would
ask the mythical beast is just like give
it a chance
don't see it as a threat hopefully what
we've talked about today has
if that was your concern that you you
understand that this is a this is about
um
personal expression and ultimately a
healthy thing that is not a
existential threat to mythical or
anything rhett link
if anything an enhancement to what we're
doing here um
but also share it with people who you
think might like it
that's all i'll say awesome
all right i think you're supposed to
have a wreck are you wrecking your own
single
man
it seems like you kind of have to just
do it just wreck your own single yeah
yeah i recommend that you go over what's
it called uh it's called believe me
and uh at some point i i am gonna have
uh there's gonna be some james and the
shame merch i don't know if that'll be
the case by the time this goes up but
there's nipple clamps there's going to
be some of that as well so you can
spread you can spread the word
uh but
i'll just say just follow me where you
listen to your music and listen
put it in your put it in a playlist
whatever you do with music
all right
next week
we'll talk at you hashtag your biscuits
hi rhett and link i was just listening
to the podcast where you're discussing
um keeping the shower curtain open or
closed when you're done with it i'm very
passionate about keeping the shower
curtain open
because
i don't want a serial killer to be
hiding behind it just thought i'd
mention it because i didn't know the
default was to keep it close all the
time so i'm here to say keep your shower
curse open so that there's no serial
killers thank you bye hi red and link my
name is molly i just wanted to let you
guys know that i just had dental surgery
and was listening to your podcast while
i was breathing in the nitrous oxide and
for a couple minutes there i transformed
myself
into
the table of dim lighting and i saw you
two
and also stevie so it was a very weird
experience but i'm very grateful for it
you guys got me through the surgery so i
think hey rhett hey link uh my name is
jesse i live in sugar grove ohio been a
fan for a long time but i'm only calling
in to say link i think the funniest
thing
about dispatches from myrtle beach
is
the pain
that you feel
when your dad says certain things i'm
listening to episode two and he was
explaining the metal fan
talking about that metal rock music and
your pause
was the funniest thing so i just
i love it uh keep doing what you do guys
bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]